my therapist and then a life coach also
was like uh have you ever just told
yourself hey i really love you i was
like no yeah
they're like okay go to the mirror right
now and do it and i and looked at myself
i was like i look
yeah as a people pleaser i felt like i
overextended myself to people who i felt
didn't like me and didn't appreciate it
more so than the people that accepted me
right like i didn't go out of my way for
those people i went out on my way for
the ones that i was like well i'll make
them like me like i'll find a way like
so they like i'll show them that i'm a
person that they can like oh my god
i just realized
the reason why i don't get angry is
because whenever i was little and i was
angry like i'm not allowed to show anger
because i don't get my ass beat so they
punished me by making me go do chores
you're getting [ __ ] done with me
it's so funny i just noticed that that's
why yeah oh [ __ ]
wow wow we just had a whole therapy
session here
[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
episode of big move hey
we didn't plan this we just all were
black and we're cute we're just sad
[ __ ] are all on our periods all right
we're mourning our uteruses up and i
just spilled my white cloth morning the
two eggs that fell down that is it
alcohol abuse
uh hello and we have a very special
guest with us today who do we have hi
guys i'm jessica zama what is up what is
up in the house thanks for having me yes
she's the best we love her thank you so
much for joining us all day today she'll
be in many episodes go check them out
um uh i guess i'm here uh nikki limo
yeah hello chris hi jessica and i'm
having a moment hi jen
you're gorgeous and i'm blushing oh
but of course we also have the beautiful
nikki limon
i'm pretty sure
and hi it's me gina and today
oh hi thanks today's episode is on how
to practice self-love what can you do
to practice self-love we found this
article on healthline
is it when you love yourself instead of
hate yourself what is that what's that
like
it's really nice
it takes a long time to do that healthy
right yeah
yeah i for a longest time i didn't know
what
self-love was like for a long time i was
like yeah i'm [ __ ] cool right you
know like sometimes it's like oh it's
when you like um put a face mask on like
you put a spot and then you that's
because that's what i hear is like oh
you gotta practice self-love and like
get a manicure whatever yeah yeah it's
really not that yeah self-love is like
morphed into self-care
right i do like i'm cool i love myself
but there's more to that yeah like what
is that like you almost like you have to
go deeper than that yeah for like the
longest time i always heard women say
like i love myself i love who i am and i
was like yeah me too
like i don't get it but it goes so much
deeper than that it's a whole like
mental thing emotional thing and it's
just it's more than skin deep and
getting pedicures so but i like them i
do love cures too i love a pedicure yeah
i got a pedicure a couple weeks ago and
then like randomly a week or two later
my pinky nail popped off oh just wait oh
the whole nail yeah you tweeted about
this and i said you need to eat a
vegetable yeah yeah
i just get some freaking nutrients yeah
i just say like a single vegetable it
would have probably stayed on yeah
zucchini or something pedicure's all
messed up but there was another nail
underneath i don't know man what oh wow
so you generate something
else yeah there you go yeah i'm like an
x-men but that's my only power it's
weird power grow nails yeah
that's why xavier never called me just
looking at people
all right the first uh this article is
called 13 steps to achieving total
self-love and the first one is stop
comparing yourself to others we're
socialized to be competitive so
comparing ourselves to others is natural
but it can be dangerous there's just no
point comparing yourself to anyone else
on the planet because there's only one
you rather focus on yourself and your
journey the shift of energy alone will
help you feel free this is such a big
one right it is and it's easier said
than done because like you can say all
you want like oh yeah i don't compare
myself but when you're scrolling through
your instagram feed or social media i
think social media is really amplified
this whole comparison
and you're seeing like people's
highlight reels
it's really hard to feel like am i not
doing enough am i behind yeah i'm doing
more everyone else crushing it in the
like in the world except for me yeah and
then
you have to take a step back and realize
that this this is really like there's i
love all these memes like oh the
internet's not real and it's fake and
people are showing like like home decor
places uh
accounts that i follow are showing the
mess behind
their pictures you know they're like
it's not real like it's just we're just
showing off the parts that we're proud
of but you know
it's not like we're always perfect yeah
we're always happy yeah that's another
thing like something that i love is when
people actually share what they're going
through and not they're not just beams
of sunshine just shooting out of their
ass all the time and they have bad days
yeah you know like the life can be messy
and things can get sticky and like
that's what i want to know about other
things shooting out of their ass too
yeah
that i don't need to see but you know
it's nice to know about it i love to see
it
all right
don't shame me okay
but it's true like um one of the best
examples i had that i learned early on
was when i was about i was about 25 and
there's this girl that i was
acquaintances with on facebook and
instagram and she was in this wonderful
relationship you know like they were
happy they're going on trips he's buying
her nice things and they're so like
their pictures are so cute and i was
like man like i want that that's so cool
and then like one day i was like
scrolling through facebook at two in the
morning and she had posted a status
she's like i'm drunk and i need someone
to help me he he always abuses me i'm
not happy and he keeps hitting me please
help me oh my god yeah
and then the post disappeared like an
hour later after people like were
blowing up her comments are you okay
okay and that's when i realized holy
[ __ ] like people are really good at just
showing the best parts but it could be
[ __ ] awful behind all that they're
just
um they're just i think someone said
like when couples are constantly posting
look how great we are look how great we
are look how great we are a lot of times
they are doing terrible behind the
scenes not so great yeah there were a
lot of people who were surprised by my
divorce and it wasn't because we were
doing horribly but we weren't doing
amazingly yeah but you only post that
you're doing amazingly yeah because like
sometimes it's like what's the fine line
between
sharing
the ups and downs and like airing dirty
laundry exactly right you know and so
you're like trying not to share the bad
things but then like and i do that with
my mental health like sometimes i'm like
i don't want to over share my depression
but like i do think like letting people
know that it's a real thing and like
it's not like every day is like i'm
rollerblading through the sunshine with
the freaking rose-colored glasses on
although i did just do that um
it's not every day you know some days
you're
you know curled up in a ball in your bed
and you can't feel like you don't feel
like getting out and you don't know how
to and you feel like um everything is
crumbling yeah i think it's really
normal to like make the bed so you don't
have to get back in it right so you
can't get back in it but i feel like yes
people should share i love when you do
your mental health posts oh thank you
because it's relatable like we all have
down days and [ __ ] days and we're not
gonna fail our best and comparison's a
thief of joy here i go again being the
elderly millennial and being a hallmark
yeah
i love it i love you it's not even like
it's not even a hormone commercial
because it's so authentically you it's
true though right you just you're a
cheerleader yeah you always have the
right mom things to say thank that like
make you go oh i needed that today i
want to be the internet mom but like a
cool mom i want you to be my mom she's
like a hot mom yeah she'll make a tick
tock out of it okay it's me your
internet mom oh i like that you can
teach kids lessons and be like hey for
those of you who didn't have a mom today
i'm going to show you how to do laundry
i would love you guys oh my gosh dude i
would watch that
you brilliant little brain big brain big
brain brilliant big brain little small
brush
yes okay or you can also do like hey
it's me your teen mom for those of you
two moms out there i can teach you
whatever if you're having a [ __ ] day
it's totally normal yeah i want to watch
that channel right now right yeah me too
i needed it yeah
exactly um the whole like you know but
sharing sharing the depression stuff
it's like
i don't want it to feel like a grab for
sympathy or like um some sort of like
attention thing i just want to share
so that you know it's like it's a
balance balance not alone yeah and that
it will get better yeah and that you can
make it through exactly because it is
like a it is kind of draining watching i
i mean i personally and this is just
you know i go through waves of just not
checking social media not
solely because i'm comparing myself but
like there's a it can make you feel bad
after a while of just like i'm not doing
enough b enough and i just spent like
three hours looking at other people's
lives
and i i don't feel like this is
productive
and it doesn't feel good on your on your
brain because i'm in the fitness world
so i'm seeing all these girls you know
when you're in 20 you could do whatever
you want you could you didn't have to
sleep you could smoke stay up late and
you would wake up and you're chiseled
and you just cut you like a greek god um
i'm 41 so you i gotta work for these abs
so it's just it's it i even struggle
with the comparison thing and sometimes
i'm just like i need a detox i'm just
not gonna scroll i'm just gonna just
yeah i think everyone goes through it
like even no matter how the person that
you're looking at that's like wow they
got their [ __ ] together look at them on
top of the world like i guarantee you
they don't know they're scrolling and
they're like why am i not like this
person you know there's always some
other
person that you're looking at so yeah it
really is true the best thing to do is
as much as you can just
when you see that and you feel those
feelings so good for them and like be
happy with your your lane and like i'm
going this way
send them wellness and then be like you
know just do your best because your best
is enough mm-hmm you know and sometimes
that's all you can do and that's okay
all you can do is all you can do and all
you can do is okay isn't enough is
enough i feel really bad for kids
growing up in this day and age with
social media because they really do have
a lot more to compare slammed in
yo we had [ __ ] up makeup until we was
like yeah twenty two three years old
exactly yeah because we didn't have
videos like teaching you how to do
perfect makeup
these eight-year-olds are doing perfect
winged liner and like how the you don't
even need that i feel like and it's
almost like i'm like
offended in a way like how dare you not
go through the shitty eyeliner and blue
eyeshadow yeah the blue eyeshadow and
sparkles and sparkles you know yeah
or the frosty
[Applause]
all
white
eyeshadows
off yeah exactly hoping these sharpies
on
but how come you didn't get to go
through the ugly phase you have like a
perfect cup crease right now
everyone needs an ugly face builds
character but they don't see it that way
because there's so many everyone knows
how to do a perfect cut crease right
because you because you have it
everyone's shoving it in your face all
the time
number two is don't worry about others
opinions in that same vein don't worry
about what society thinks or expects of
you you can't make everyone happy so
this is a waste of time and will only
slow you down on your journey to
becoming the best you that's also really
hard to do it is really hard to do
the best thing is to think about how
like you're never going to make everyone
happy it's exhausting if you try it's
going to be someone that doesn't like
you for their own reasons like you can't
even control their reasons you just
can't so
don't stress about it because there's no
way you can do it you can't control them
yeah there's another one good the people
that matter don't mind the people that
mine don't matter yeah
see the boom i told you i'm jersey okay
do this tick tock channel and sell the
posters right
yeah that's your mom i love it
there's a little right there's a quote
by uh that says you can be the ripest
prettiest juiciest peach in the world
and there's still going to be people out
there who don't like peaches that's
absolutely true that's true and she's
juicy yeah and it's that it is hard to
do it's hard to not um
care about other people's opinions but i
made a rule for myself uh back in like
my
later 20s
where for the most part working in
entertainment i don't really give a [ __ ]
what people say about me because if you
really care about what every single one
says about you you're going to be
[ __ ] insane
but personally i have a rule where if i
hear
uh the same critique about me three
times from people around me or like my
first circle my circle if i hear it at
least three times that's when i step
back i'm like okay
or maybe maybe i should maybe there is
some evaluation yes i'll reevaluate yeah
or like or sometimes comments online too
or people are like oh she's so [ __ ]
self-centered and then i'll i was like
kind of you know like if i hear it
enough times like three times at least
i'll reevaluate and i'll really sit with
myself about that's so healthy to do
that's true it's really great to take
ownership or acknowledge something like
to not be like
so egoic that you're invincible to
criticism
mine was a defensiveness i never knew
that i was defensive at all but like i
had started hearing that like a lot and
i realized like yeah i mean i touched my
therapist i was like yeah i mean i feel
really misunderstood and like i feel
like the worst feeling
i've ever felt is being misunderstood
like when my intentions were this and
like everyone's taking it as this and so
then i get really defensive because i'm
like wait no no no that's not like
that's not what happened like let me
explain like that's not like no you're
wrong like this is and and people
aren't
it's not an attractive it doesn't make
people want to listen to you when you're
just coming out of defensiveness and so
i really had to understand what
defensiveness was and why
when it was that people were saying i
was acting that way
and and then understand how to better
articulate or like to give um to
understand where they're coming from
before
telling them where i'm coming from stuff
like that you know little things that i
think help me be
a better person and improve ultimately
but it was really hard because i
because you know how do you separate
just the general trolling criticism hate
comments from like the actual legitimate
ones that are like hey maybe this is
something like
you could fix about yourself or you're
so self-aware though which i think is
really special and i think when you're
young you aren't so self-aware and you
don't you're not so introspective
something that i did when i was
probably until like last year um besides
over-extending myself as i was a people
pleaser yeah and i've realized that
though i
as a human being i want to be liked by
someone i'm not going to go out of my
way to prove to them why they should
like me if they don't yeah because i'm
they just don't like peaches and don't
you feel like as a people pleaser i felt
like i overextended myself to people who
i felt didn't like me and didn't
appreciate it more so than the people
that accepted me right like i didn't go
out of my way for those people i went
out of my way for the ones that i was
like well i'll make them like me like
i'll find a way like so they like i'll
show them that i'm a person that they
can like right and you are you're so
likable like what's not to like yeah
it's an exciting people don't like
peaches it's very interesting because
like i it's it's very surprising hearing
that from you because to me you're a
very
intelligent woman who knows yourself and
stuff like that and then you just saying
that makes me realize that you people
are constantly learning about themselves
all the time no matter like our age
difference or where we are in life you
know like people are constantly always
learning nobody has it all completely
figured out and you don't need to have
it figured out by a certain age at all
you know no i don't i think it takes
it's a lifetime of learning right and
when we stop learning like that's when
we stop growing as people yeah i also
realized i like harbor a lot of rage in
my belly and we just talked about this
before yeah yeah it's the abs um
that i was a teen mom and i was a single
mom so there's just so much anger and
emotion that i wasn't able to express so
it's repressed yeah and now i'm just
like you know i can be like a sour patch
baby i could be really sweet or i could
like try to bite your ankles yeah so you
gotta watch out for me
it's not because she's going after
angles it's just that's how tall she is
yeah it's also because i'm four ten and
a
half
whether it's a warm cup of coffee
basking in warm sunlight or listening to
a sexy story
pleasure is all around us with dipsy
your sanctuary is waiting escape to a
world where pleasure is your only
priority dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women that's right
they bring scenarios to life with
immersive soundscapes and characters no
matter who you're into or what turns you
on if you catch my drift i don't know we
don't judge you can find stories about
that intriguing co-worker with a british
accent or hooking up with your hat yoga
instructor hot in multiple ways the yoga
and the
guy they even have stories designed
specifically for your zodiac sign ooh
okay dipsy also has sleep stories so if
you have trouble going to sleep they
have like stories that will lull you
into a nice dream state they have
wellness sessions and they now also
offer written stories it's your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies or just heat things up
with a partner for our listeners deepsea
is offering an extended 30-day free
trial when you go to dipsystories.com
big mood that's 30 days of full access
for free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood dipsy stories
dot com slash mood get in the mood you
know
if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress then your sleep will be
terrible it's that simple that's why i
recommend sleeping on a purple mattress
purple mattresses have the gel flex grid
it's a super stretchy ultra squishy
material that adapts and flexes around
pressure points and doesn't retain heat
the gel flux grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders neck and hips
no matter how you like to sleep unlike
memory foam which remembers everything
the gel flex grid purple mattresses
bounce back as you move and shift you'll
never have that i'm stuck feeling people
get with memory foam try your purple
mattress risk-free with free shipping
and returns financing is available too i
sleep really hot i always wake up so
sweaty but with purple it doesn't happen
anymore because it's so breathable it
keeps you nice and cool getting a great
night's sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
pro.com big mood 10 and use code big
mood 10. for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com big boot 10 code big move 10
for 10 off any order of 200 or more once
again that's purple.com big mood 10
promo code bigmood10 terms apply the
next one is oh i really like this one
it's
uh allow yourself to make mistakes we're
told again and again from a young age
that nobody's perfect and everyone makes
mistakes but the older you get the more
pressure you feel never to fail cut
yourself some slack make mistakes so you
can learn and grow from them embrace
your past uh you're constantly changing
and growing from who you once were into
who you are today and who you will be
one day so forget about that voice in
the head that says you need to be
perfect make mistakes lots of them the
lessons you'll gain are priceless i
personally really love this one because
i have experience with this one um
growing up i grew up with my
grandparents but my siblings my my
second
brother
second eldest brother he growth my dad
and my dad it was very militant um
very cleanly like he was a uh like he
was he was a felon back then so he's
very hard on himself he's very hard you
have to be a man you have to do this you
have to do this right you have to do
that right why are you gonna do this
right and it gave my brother like a
complex like toxic masculinity not toxic
masculinity but if he does something
wrong he has a full down like a full
breakdown
yeah like i i think it's so important
for yes you need to encourage your kids
to do their best and you know um try
their hardest but you also really need
to teach them how to fail well too and
accept failure because
back then my brother if he got like a
bad grade or he didn't do something
right or didn't clean something right he
would have a meltdown and it was
heartbreaking you know like you have to
teach your kids that if you fail at
something the world's not gonna end it's
just that you have chances to try again
and again and again or
it if you don't teach them that they're
going to be too scared to even try
anything at all because they don't want
to fail and they just get stuck in this
limbo where like they just won't do
anything at all and it's like the first
or the way when you fail it's another
step to success yeah yeah you have to
keep failing and then
eventually you learn you learn and you
become better at it so
seeing the how my dad raised my brother
really taught me like you really need to
learn how to fail in a healthy way
absolutely i heavily relate to that um
by the way a good book to read is
failing forward by john c maxwell that's
a great book um but
that's how i was raised and i was the
firstborn and my dad super militant and
like perfectionist and
um i
really just ha
as even as an adult carried that through
where like if i made a little mistake i
was
full-blown meltdown like steve really
had to help me with that like hey you
know it's not a big deal a lot of people
make that mistake like it's not at the
end of the world but even little things
i was just like oh you suck at my
failures
i'm never gonna be good at anything um
and that's why i have the [ __ ] perfect
line the uh you know i saw you wear the
ring i was like
um
yeah cause [ __ ] perfect you
really don't learn anything until you
fail and i think that's the problem with
the way that we're raised not just if
your dad's like that or your mom's like
that but even in school like you get a
bad grade if you [ __ ] up like you made
a mistake if you didn't do well on a
test if you didn't learn the way they
taught you to learn or whatever like you
are failing like in your they're telling
you like it's bad you're not gonna get a
job you're not gonna go to the school
you wanna go to and so you're trained
from very young to like mistakes are bad
don't make mistake don't [ __ ] up
otherwise you have severe consequences
of it and
then you're so scared to take a risk
outside of your comfort zone because
what if you fail then it must be the end
of the world it must mean that you you
will
all every all your security will be
taken away from you
um and i i just think that's not true i
just uh think from experience that
failing has been the the best thing for
me ever and and so many
so many ways of it not working led me to
the way that it did work
so yeah i i hate that people feel like
they can't fail um
when i do the bullet journal stuff i
even i talk about i talk about this on
my channel um because so many people are
like oh like i want to do a bullet
journal but i'm not artistic or i it
looks so good when other people do it
but i can't do it i'm like yo just [ __ ]
it it's not for anyone but you like if
anywhere you can [ __ ] up it's in your
bullet journal like you like try
something try something that you don't
know if you can do and experiment and
you'll get better and you'll learn to be
like oh if i just press this way instead
of this way it makes the lettering go
better or smooth smoother or flow better
and and you're learning that's how
literally how you learn to walk is by
falling
like that's from a baby
you're just not a walker yeah yeah
you're going to crawl forever sorry yeah
none of the cards freed up i think i
think sometimes too the fear of failure
can be ultra paralyzing to people so
they don't try
um but i think it's gonna be like as
human beings it's progress not
perfection like it's are we constantly
learning about ourselves i'm constantly
learning about myself i had to fail so
many i've lived
19 lives in this lifetime you know i've
done it all i've
seen it all done at all said it all and
i also don't regret anything because
every single decision i've made every
wrong turn right turn has led me to
exactly where i'm at today so you have
to on this car
on this couch with you guys all in black
where else would you want to be baby
right here nowhere else
and it's it's everything that you've
done in your life has led you to where
you are and you can't regret that you
have to be okay with like yes
you have to fail to succeed yeah and
it's scary it's not slightly scary it's
not [ __ ] easy like it's not like yay
go fail i did it you can too it's like
no one knows what they're doing it
[ __ ] hurts it hurts you skin your
knees and you're like [ __ ] can i walk i
don't know maybe maybe i have to crawl
but you get back up and you do it again
you try a different way you re-angle
yourself you look at other people that
are walking you're like maybe if i try
it this way and and you learn and then
it feels so good because it feels like
when you actually get when you get the
prize when you get you know the meat and
potatoes you're like i earned this meal
i did it yeah i finally got there you
have to fall so many times to walk and
then when you figure it out you walk
pigeon toed like nikki
walker
i think it's so cute that you're
pitching
i still trip over my feet
okay number four
remember your value doesn't lie in how
your body looks this is fundamental so
many things in the world want to
distract you from this powerful truth
sometimes even your own internalized
sexism affirms your thoughts of
inadequacy you are valuable because you
are you not because of your body so
where it makes you feel good if it's a
lot or if it's a little wear what makes
you feel confident comfortable and happy
uh 100 000 i tell clients all the time
it's not how you look it's how you feel
yeah how do you feel do you feel good
yeah are you you have energy you have
energy how do you feel vitality
absolutely what's your mental health
what's your heart health like you can
have the best body and be shitty on the
inside and it's worth nothing yeah
yeah a lot of people don't even know how
unhealthy they are like they were always
just naturally skinny or naturally like
built certain ways and then they're like
oh yeah i didn't think i was i had to
check on my health by the way who told
us what a good body is what a perfect
body is like media it's horrible like
your body is your body and this is the
only body we get in our lifetime so we
better be happy with it it's tilted more
towards women for sure
and maybe gay guys um because like you
in society you're taught that that is
where your value is is in your beauty
your youth and beauty because
traditionally in the old days
you
were
there to be married and make babies and
so the more fertile you look which is
when you're younger is the more valuable
you are because that is your job in
society someone will marry you and make
a baby yes hopefully it is someone with
superior genetics and so you are to
attract the one and then biologically
your children have a better chance of
living longer all biological right but
it's so outdated because you don't need
that anymore and so now you can actually
understand your value as a person as a
whole person as a whole human being yeah
um and i see the same thing as you
you
have one vessel in life right your body
your face whatever
and you decorate it however you want to
decorate it that's why i was like
plastic surgery if this is what i want
my vessel to look like i'm gonna [ __ ]
do it other people if you want like 1600
piercings on your vessel go ahead you
know
and i think it's i think that's the best
thing to kind of understand about
yourself but also
understand that like this is your vessel
decorate however you want but at the end
of the day when
what your opinion of your own beauty is
gone because we all eventually get old
you know we all like we don't have the
tight bodies that we used to have what's
on the inside like if you're a shitty
person on the inside it doesn't matter
anymore like you can marry someone that
you find so insanely hot whatever and if
that's all you're marrying for what
happens when you're like 90 years old
and you have nothing to talk about and
you [ __ ] hate each other full surface
another interesting thing is when you
look at older like old
like seniors
um
it your what you feel on the inside ends
up on the outside like people that are
like spent their life angry they have a
permanent scowl on their face you can
see like angry old men and women that
they're they can't unfurl their face
it's just permanently this and then the
ones that are happy and like let like
kind of had a happier freer
time in life you can see it like they're
they're they've got like a permanent
smile and it's so interesting that the
end you really see the inside go on the
outside yeah it seeps out it makes its
way out so i hope what's seeping out is
nice like we have to crack ourselves
like wide open as people and it's like
what's in there yeah what am i made up
of like what's in there when i ate first
there was one time i did a photo shoot
um and we were like of course photoshoot
has a lot of makeup and like we were out
in the sun and i was dehydrated because
i drink like a couple water a month
and
i looked in the mirror and i saw like
lines here
and i was like oh my god is that my
first wrinkle and i was like
i'm really kind of glad that it's a
smile line and not like a friend yeah
that's cool it shows how you live yeah
yeah mine are all up here from like last
lap
yeah i'm like i'm kind of cool with that
and then later on i washed out some
makeup moisturizers i was like oh it's
okay it's just the makeup and it's okay
there's just some makeup
oh oops not a wrinkle
i'm young
[Laughter]
number five oh i love this one don't be
afraid to let go of toxic people not
everybody takes responsibility for the
energy they put into the world if
there's someone who is bringing you
toxicity into their life and you want to
resolve things in a bloodier way i'm so
proud
and they won't take responsibility for
it that might mean you need to step away
from them that might mean you need to
study a type of nwa there you go
don't be afraid to do this it's
liberating and important even though it
may be painful remember protect your
energy it's not rude or wrong to remove
yourself from situations or the company
of people who are draining you emotional
vampires are real and it's not time
that's fleeting it is our energy like we
only have so much of it and we have to
protect who we give it to and where we
put it when you talk about being a
people pleaser it's like you definitely
encounter
you definitely like somehow are
magnetized to the ones that want to
drain your energy absolutely they see
that and they're like oh you have an s
on your chest save me yeah
yeah i as i grew older
i realized that i don't really
care to keep
certain people around like some people
are harder to get rid of others because
of my history and all that right it's
true yeah but other people was like
i don't really like give a [ __ ] about
you yeah enough to [ __ ] bother you
know you
uh i you made this one of my friends
unhappy you made said some weird things
to me like all right yeah i'm good yeah
if people aren't bringing value into
your life and then you into theirs it's
you know it's a two-way street so it has
to be reciprocated and if you aren't
mutually enhancing each other's lives
there's really no point yeah
like
before i'd be like no i can't unfollow
them or unfriend them it's gonna be so
weird now just like
you're out when are you gonna see them
again really yeah
you can break up with your family too
absolutely and if it's very toxic mm-hmm
a lot of people don't think you can but
you totally can you definitely can yeah
it's healthy too it's set boundaries
yeah
uh the next one is
process your fears like airing feeling
afraid is a natural is natural and human
don't reject your fears understand them
this healthy exercise can help
with your mental health interrogating
and evaluating your fears helps you to
gain clarity and unmask issues in your
life that were causing you anxiety
that in turn can help you alleviate some
if not all of your anxiety yes i'm not
afraid yes
i started going to therapy and
very good yeah thanks it was your
therapist oh yeah this is the [ __ ]
and she like during our first few
sessions she didn't exercise with me
she's like all right we're gonna figure
out like what you're most afraid of
and going in i'm like i already am
pretty self-aware kind of know what's
going on already
but she helped me figure it out and she
said one thing and i just bawled my eyes
out like it was [ __ ] weird i because
i thought i knew so much about me yeah
she tap that button exactly she's like
this is what you fear the most
and the fact that i
cried and just like broke down
i was really thankful for that because i
could have gone my whole entire life not
understanding what i was so afraid of
totally or were too fair too afraid to
even find out you know but she helped me
and it gave me like this huge like
massive clarity in life i'm like oh this
is why i do the things that i do and i'm
so like i'm so glad that i went through
that yeah a lot of people are afraid to
confront those their biggest fear is
confronting their fears yeah um i think
there's a i think that is what your
shadow self is there's like a part of
all of us that we kind of keep hidden um
whether it's because we don't we're
embarrassed we don't want society to
know that part of us we're we're scared
of people knowing that part of us or um
it's like a fear like we don't want to
believe that that part of us exists
right
and to be a whole person they say you
have to uncover
and confront your shadow self and like
not just confront it but also
embrace those parts and understand how
you can
use them in a healthy way to balance
your life out i don't have a good
example really of that but i mean we
talked about earlier of just like taking
criticisms into consideration and you
know examine a lot of times when you're
um
judging other people for something it's
an inner projection of something that
you're insecure about so like taking a
look at that
there's a book that tiff actually gave
me
she gave all of us yeah called burn
after
burn after writing or something
burn no i think she gave us a cute book
about the sisters that was recently oh
but like two years ago said about doing
a brain dump and then setting it on yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i love doing that
yeah it's called like burn after writing
or something like that but it really is
about
like it gives you prompts and questions
to like really think about
these parts of yourself that you might
be hiding from that you don't want to
confront absolutely and like why you're
doing that and what happened in your
past to make you feel do have these
parts to like trigger them because they
feel like a part of
acknowledging your fears and confronting
them is acknowledging your emotions and
for a long time i didn't acknowledge my
emotions i never even let them see the
light of day i'm just like nope i'm on
reddit
yes i gotta be a mom yes i'm gonna be
strong i'm in survivor
hair goes on my warrior makeup and i
kind of just plowed through life and i'm
really good at doing that i'm really
good at playing through life i have to
watch like really sad movies to cry
which feels very robotic but i'm like oh
at least i can cry
because
where's the disney channels come on
cinderella um but i
just allowing myself to feel my feelings
has helped me tremendously mentally
because then
i can hold space for someone all day
long it's part of my profession it's
part of my legacy but to hold space for
myself was really healing that's
something i wasn't used to doing yeah i
know i know you and i know we've talked
about this before too but i'm so proud
of you that you're able to acknowledge
that and all even you acknowledging your
rage inside
yeah like you have this fire and it's
not a bad thing i mean yeah it's like
okay if a poor soul happens to stumble
upon you at the wrong moment
maybe it said they're the line of fire
and it's like oh sorry i definitely use
pain for power for sure
that's my driving force but i do think
it's good to acknowledge that pain
sometimes when it comes and it's
drifting your way on that boat instead
of taking my foot and kicking it away
and be like not today yeah sometimes i'm
like oh hi boat with emotions hey pain
hi pain what do you need yeah yeah i
think it also i'm kind of mixing a lot
of things up that i've learned from a
therapist but like there's an inner
child in you and sometimes it throws a
tantrum when you're not giving her what
she wants listen to me yeah and it was
stuff that you denied yourself when you
were an actual child or that was denied
to you by other people when you were an
actual child and these are like basic
needs that you know children need to be
happy and healthy and whole and they
were denied and so
it doesn't just go away you can't just
stifle it down it's like it sits there
and she lives there and she lives there
with her needs unmet and sometimes out
of nowhere she's gonna throw a tantrum
when it gets triggered and you don't
know where it's coming from until you
really dig deep and
and go what is where is this stemming
from like what how hi how can i help you
i love a tantrum and that's something i
think as parents is a great thing to
give to our children is coping in life
because there's going to be a day that
you're not around to hold space for them
and to protect them and support them and
so if what we can do is like teach our
children to be strong that they can
stand on their own and that no one's
coming to save them they have to save
themselves i think that's a really good
what are your coping mechanisms what are
your coping mechanisms in life and how
are you taking care of you first you got
to put the mask on yourself first for
you can help anyone else you know the
oxygen mask yeah moms need to hear that
especially but everyone does yeah it's
hard especially as a mom because you
want to swoop in and save your kids
first before yourself i can hold my
breath here
that's what my therapist always told me
too like you have to secure your own
oxygen mask first before anyone else
uh the next one is
trust yourself to make good decisions
for yourself we so often doubt ourselves
and our ability to do what's right when
most of the time we do know in our
hearts and what's best remember that
your feelings are valid you're not
losing touch with reality you know
yourself better than anyone else so be
your best advocate
yes yes
like they always speak about
women's intuition right
and i've like that's how i got into
trouble with people before it's just
like i my gut was telling me one thing
but i'm like nah nah yeah let me follow
this logic yeah they're not that bad
yeah yeah you know and then that's it
always ended up being [ __ ] i was right
all along it's so true
and
i read this thing on reddit that said
you know like you spent your whole
entire life around other human beings
you know how human beings
are you know how they act you know how
they function so if something is off
you're right you know and that it it it
includes like if you're walking down the
street at night this person just seems
like it's it's kind of shady or whatever
like trust your gut and trust your
intuition because you know how people
are normally yeah if alarm bells are
ringing in your body
more often right than wrong exactly
every time i've tried to go off of my
like logic instead over intuition
usually they're in lockstep but like
sometimes it's like i don't know why it
doesn't seem logical but i think we
should go this way instead of that way
every time i've tried to ignore it like
nah that doesn't make sense like this
this is the way i figured it out
it's always been wrong yeah i'm always
like [ __ ] i was my intuition was right
yeah
i can't remember what show it is and
that's that's exactly what the show's
about but it's about it talks to people
who have had these near-death
experiences every single one of them
said that their their intuition told
them don't go down that alley or don't
talk to this person or steer clear of
that and that's very telling and also
terrifying you have to really learn to
listen to that yeah like even if it
doesn't make sense to you it doesn't
need to make sense like if something is
like really ringing like don't do it
just don't do it yeah follow that good
interesting sense yeah you'll find out
later why i think maybe like i wonder if
it's like it it boils down to because we
are
pretty much animals and that animal
instinct that we have from back then are
all those survival instincts that we've
had back then as
cavemen and stuff like maybe it's stuck
with us for this long
and it kind of manifests or shows itself
too and it still helps us yeah right
absolutely and that being said uh
because i've learned a lot from from
playing poker it's all about decision
making and
your emotions
your um lack of hydration
and drugs and alcohol
severely impair your decision making
like
like more than you i know you know that
it impairs your decision making because
like don't drink and drive like that
kind of stuff but like i didn't realize
how much
dehydration
makes you not think correctly and lack
of sleep
or a lack of eating or lack of like if
your basic needs aren't being met you
are terrible at making decisions even if
your brain tells you like no no we gotta
good now we got this no you you don't so
like really take care of your health and
your basic human needs before making any
important decisions at all huh
yeah yeah i could have been a [ __ ]
ceo of a fortune 500 country company
right now drink that water right here
should that you should drink some water
gina you can still do it
have a vegetable for once in your life
oh how'd i lose the page what the hell
is this did i click on an ad because you
didn't drink enough water seriously
if she had drinking water she would not
lose her place
access to reproductive health care has
become much harder and unnecessarily
complicated for women in recent years
gain time and peace of mind back with
favor their licensed medical team puts
your health first with access to
affordable birth control skin care
menstrual care sexual wellness products
and more all with an online subscription
the pill club is now favor favor offers
professionally prescribed birth control
subscriptions and sexual wellness
products delivered straight to your door
for free favor carries over 120 fda
approved brands and ships to all 50
states most brands of birth control are
free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance
favor delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies oh i wish it was always like
that what's more their licensed medical
team is just a text away to provide you
the care that you deserve sign up for
birth control in just five minutes skip
the office visit waiting in line at the
pharmacy and get treated right right now
when you go to hayfavor.com
big mood favor is offering a 10 donation
to bedsider.org for every big mood
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's heyfavor.com
big mood to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember
heyfavor.com big mood you must use the
link to make the donation the key to
consistent good hair days using
ingredients that benefit your hair
functional beauty makes hair products
that are 100 customizable made for your
hair where it's at now and where you
want it to go functional beauty is the
world's first fully customizable hair
care that creates individually filled
shampoos conditioners styling and
treatment formulas based on your hair
now and where you want to go founded by
a dream team of engineers and cosmetic
scientists each functional beauty
product is individually designed to be
as unique as you are functioning beauty
offers over 54 trillion possible
formulations every one of them is vegan
and cruelty free and they never use
phosphates or parabens you can also go
completely silicone free here's how it
works first take the quick hair quiz to
build your hair profile and select five
hair goals like lengthen volumize and
oil control does your hair get frizzy in
the winter but oily in the summer
function formulations are meant to be
changed when your needs change next
choose your color and fragrance or go
dire fragrance free too i usually get
purple and i like rose scented then get
your freshly filled formula delivered
straight to your door and prepare for
good hair days ahead say goodbye to
generic haircare for good today go to
functionbeauty.com big moods take your
hair goals quiz and you'll save 25 on
your first order again let's go to
functionalbeauty.com to let them know
you heard about it on our show and to
get 25 off your first order that's
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your hair quiz and save
25 on your first order the next one is
number eight says
take every opportunity life presents or
create your own the timing is never
going to be perfect for that next big
step in your life the setup may not be
ideal but that shouldn't hold you back
from reaching to meet your goals and
dreams instead seize the moment because
it may never come back
i love saying say yes and then figure it
out
yeah like even if you don't know how
mm-hmm especially if you're in tuition's
telling you that yes like i mean not if
it's like
oh i'm gonna you know
move to jamaica on a whim and like put
my job there's a difference between
being impulsive and like taking an
opportunity
yeah
they say that luck is when preparation
meets opportunities so if there's
something that you've been preparing for
and you've just been waiting for the
opportunity obviously
even if you're like i don't know if i'm
ready you're ready [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] do
it that reminds me of when i was like
early 20s when i first met like
uh all my youtube buddies
and for the longest time i refused to
post anything on my channel they're like
dude just post anything just [ __ ]
post i'm like no yeah i have to have the
perfect camera
to edit how do i like use this camera
how do i be but you guys videos look so
good i want to just post them and that
stopped me for so long
and it kept me from not really posting
normally you know and then you don't
learn because you don't know how you
haven't done anything yet
figuring out your voice as a whole thing
and
you don't want to have the fancy
equipment without having the experience
first just get in there yeah i had to
make it so perfect like even with my
stream i was like but it's not pretty i
don't have like a set up i don't have
all this whatever they're like shut my
friends like shut up and just [ __ ]
stream and now like i'm like i could
have started way earlier you know
yeah all the waiting leads to inaction
and it's like just start yeah there's no
perfect time to do it yeah it's easier
said than done totally it goes back to
that perfection thing and not wanting to
fail or make a mistake and you see other
people who are succeeding you're like
but mine doesn't look like theirs so can
i do it i didn't start there i remember
like do i have to get a dslr right away
i'm [ __ ] poor like yeah you know
it was it was tough
uh number nine says
put yourself first don't feel bad about
doing this women especially can grow
accustomed to putting others first
although there's a time and place for
this it shouldn't be a habit that costs
your mental emotional well-being
find the time to decompress without
decompressing and recharging you can put
serious strain on yourself whether it's
spending the day in bed
[Music]
or outdoors in nature find what helps
you decompress and dedicate time to this
yeah we talked about this a little bit
on one of the other episodes but like um
you know extroverts typically recharge
by
going and hanging out with people and
then introverts tend to recharge by
staying
inside and being alone um but you
definitely need some sort of outlet for
and this is where like the emotional
buildup comes in because if you don't
have an outlet for all of these emotions
and it's just built way to let it out
stress out then yeah you're just gonna
be a really tense angry person it's
going to be a little rough for you and
it's going to explode somewhere along
the line it doesn't go away ever it just
builds it builds to a breaking point
yeah that's where people go crazy and
have mental breaks and i end up in
another country somewhere midlife crisis
i was in another country having a
midlife crisis because i was in london
shooting the show and i it was the first
time in my life i've ever not had to
take care of someone whoa my girlfriend
was here my daughter was here i'm in
london in quarantine because it was just
they had us all sectioned off and
um unless it was shoot days i didn't
really see anyone and i'm like oh my
what do i do with myself yeah you didn't
even have your dog i had nothing no no
dog no girlfriend no no girlfriend there
was no alcohol it was just me and my
thoughts and there's a lot rolling up up
there so i i really learned how to be
still and being still i'm so not good at
it yeah but i i'm a reader yeah oh my
god i'm a reader
so i started to read and i um i've never
been good at meditation yeah but it's
hard it's so hard day by day slowly
slowly but surely i i learned how to be
still and that's still something that
i'm working on um but learning how to
take care of yourself first is
so important
and i didn't even know how to do it
that's what they call yoga and
meditation a practice it's a total
because it always is practice no matter
how much you've been doing it it's not
just easy for humans to be
something still like you had a breakdown
because you weren't taking care of
someone and i just imagined like
a news article like crazed american
woman brushing the hair of children
okay baby
strange babies
she's wild but i'm like that too it's
very hard for me to sit still
and it's very hard for me to sit in
silence
um so meditating just doesn't work for
me it's the strangest thing to me
uh i think i've gotten a little bit
better at it
or being in silence because before i
used to have to always sleep with the tv
on and now i don't anymore but then it
also because i have my cat yeah yeah
yeah because that's
they're very meditative actually like
when just petting them it's it's purring
yeah the purring they're actually a
great anxiety relief yeah for people
yeah yesterday okay now i want a cat
nikki
yeah we converted her
to the whole kitchen dog person is now
cat person
gateway cat good job nibbler
i forgot another one
they'll never get out dog zero cats
three
ten
says
feel pain and joy as fully as you can
allow yourselves to feel these things
fully lean into pain revel in your joy
and don't put limitations on your
feelings like fear pain and joy are
emotions that will help you understand
yourself and ultimately realize that you
are not your feelings
feel your feelings
i think i feel them too much i like i
feel every emotion so intensely and i
didn't even realize that like not
everyone feels
emotion super intensely until i became
older
i was like
everyone cries every day right
that's normal right and uh and i just
cry at every emotion like every emotion
is expressed by crying so joy if i'm
like super happy i'm crying even horny
not hoarding nothing because it'll be
weird that's not an emotion that's like
a primal need i think
although after sex i have cried
sometimes because it's like a release
yeah
yeah um but really when i'm sad when i'm
happy when i'm
angry when i'm frustrated it all comes
out as crying it's like this overwhelm
of emotion and so it comes out as like
tears yeah but i'm not like it's not
like a logical thing i'm not like i'm so
angry i'm gonna cry it's just like it
just is coming out and i'm still
thinking and trying to communicate the
same way as i would if it wasn't
happening it's your body processing yeah
and i feel like it's betraying me
sometimes i'm like wait no i'm not
i'm not emotional okay
i'm telling you something real all of my
emotions come out as anger but we all
know that anger when you're angry
there's other emotions happening
sadness frustration feeling
misunderstood
happiness i feel to my core and i i can
feel really elated a lot of the time
it's the other half of that like the
sadness i don't really feel deeply
unless i'm watching disney and crying
you could at least you found an outlet
to get there yeah totally mm-hmm lucy
lets me spin out she'll like she knows
if i'm having a moment and she's like i
just let you you're like a top and you
just spin and spin and sin until you
you're you're done and you're late you
you're done you collapse yeah and she's
like you just a lot of people just need
to let themselves spin out i think it's
that inner child thing too because like
when i was a kid i got yelled at if i
was frustrated or you know whatever i
started crying just like i do now but i
got yelled at for it because my dad
thought all emotions were bad and so
like he would yell at me and then it
would make me cry more because i'm being
yelled at and so then i was like
hyperventilating like this and i had
crazy anxiety like gee i wonder why i
got crazy anxiety as an adult
and uh and that whole inner child thing
is like letting
her just feel the emotions yeah because
you're a person and i found out much
later in life that my dad was actually
a very emotional person and he was not
allowed to be when he was a child yeah
and so it's like he's just teaching what
he learned and how he was raised to grow
up and like and how he saw that
emotions aren't accepted in the world
that you're not taking seriously as a
person and you really aren't there is a
stigma behind people that are emotional
like oh you can't be logical and
emotional at the same time so like
emotions bad women can't reach you
because you're so emotional yeah exactly
and so like he was trying to protect me
from that kind of judgment um
by like
stifling that but as we learned now like
later like modern
psychology and stuff has shown us that
it's actually very healthy to express
emotions and more people should it
shouldn't be stigmatized by society to
feel things like you're not a robot like
yeah and also it's bad it actually
causes
disease in your body that's the main
source of of the cause of disease is uh
is stress and um emotions and anything
that you're not releasing
it's a buildup of that and it creates
disharmony in your body and the body
keeps the score yes exactly so we have
to feel our feeling it's a great book we
have to feel our feelings for sure yeah
i think the feeling that i don't
express well is probably anger to be
honest yeah true you kind of like you
kind of you're like a silent anger it's
like when she goes silent it's like
yeah i'm more like a um
like a plot there murder anger yeah i'm
like a more methodical anger yeah quiet
yeah and i don't really rage and i don't
yeah like well i mean the last time i
got angry was actually a few weeks ago i
found out the significant other of a
family member was getting beaten
and they called me
and i took my baseball bat over like
that's the only time but other than that
i don't
feel anger i i've always told people i'm
at my best when i'm angry because i
don't rage i get really really
methodical and i focus i'm like i'm
hyper focused you know that's how steep
that's what steve says about himself
he's like i like getting angry because
it's a fuel yeah like i need like the
anger to fuel me to do things and i'm
like i don't understand
straight mosh
but like i never scream i never like
yell i don't punch things i don't
whatever
but sadness and happiness i got pretty
good yeah you're like that's unlocked
yeah
scream yelled and punched my car seat
yesterday
me oh yeah
yeah
so
yeah i guess
talking to you guys made me realize i
don't remember being angry ever even
when i'm arguing with people interesting
i don't scream or yell maybe because
your outlet is productivity when you're
angry i think so yeah i really think so
but those are the two things people
don't talk about that we should talk
about more is our one our emotions and
to our mental health
and
removing the stigmatism but the stigma
behind mental health and that
conversation because it all comes down
to emotion and like what's happening
between our head and in here and like
intuition and all the things it's all
yeah it's not a coincidence that if you
look at the psychology behind all every
serial killer there's trauma during
childhood it's always like some
traumatic thing happened in their
childhood oh my god i just realized
the reason why i don't get angry is
because whenever i was little and i was
angry like they would my grandparents
like yell at me or whatever or um if i
not like oh what is it if they yell at
me i'm not allowed to show anger because
i don't get my ass beat so they punished
me by making me go do chores oh
you're getting [ __ ] done with me
it's so funny oh i just noticed that
that's why yeah it's like you're not a
mechanism
and like you're not allowed foreign yell
because it's like i'll just close the
door i'm like
whispering exactly just whispering
it yeah oh [ __ ]
wow wow we just had a whole therapy
session here we had a breakthrough
we have to break down to break through
wow that's so cool she's got a lot of
merch coming out i hope you are
subscribing to her um well we're running
out of time because every point of these
were so good that we
had a lot to talk about with each point
but just to uh speed through the rest of
him um number 11 is exercise boldness in
public get into the habit of speaking
your mind boldness is like a muscle it
grows the more you exercise it and it's
true i used to be a very shy [ __ ] yeah
and now i yell at people in public i
love dancing in public yeah there's a
fine line between that and karen though
right oh no i yell at carrots
yeah yeah i used to be afraid of
conflict and stuff like that but now i
yell at karen's um let's see 12 is see
beauty and the simple things try to
notice at least one beautiful small
thing around the earth oh yeah i have
been doing that that's youtube it helps
you
she doesn't mean it
it helps to be more present too because
sometimes we just go about life and
we're like i know what that is there's a
tree there's a car on the street i've
been here a million [ __ ] times like i
know a neighborhood and you're not
really
observing like you're not really present
be in your life but if you can observe
like one beautiful thing that you didn't
notice before you're you're here yeah
you're in the world you are here and
you're you you matter here and you're
valued here like you're a valuable
person you're a valuable person i think
that's what we need to tell one another
more too yeah you're valuable
you matter here you need to be internet
mom i want to be internet i want to tell
you
boyfriends and internet husbands and
like you know the people hey honey how
was your day yeah i made you dinner how
to let me rub your feet like they have
that [ __ ] you could be the mom i'm going
to be the mom yeah i would love it but i
love that you see the beauty and simple
things like i really try to maintain and
keep my child like wonder so sometimes
i'm just staring at a [ __ ] bee and
i'm like yeah that's beautiful yeah and
my friend's like the [ __ ] going on you
can't lose that yeah never lose that it
makes me happy like that's why like as
as how i am and whatever when i'm at
home i'm a [ __ ] child
bunny ears
maybe that's why you like aries because
we're childlike oh maybe yeah yeah
and then the last one and probably the
most important one is to be kind to
yourself the world is full of harsh
words and critique don't add yours to
the mix speak kindly to yourself and
don't call yourself mean things that
one's really hard it's very really hard
and so important my therapist told me
that i do that because i'm carrying on
what i learned from childhood so it's
like um you know i got reprimanded and
told me things when i you know would
make a mistake so when i make a mistake
now i'm just carrying on the same
punishment like they don't even need to
be there anymore i'm punishing myself
for it i'm like oh [ __ ] that's so true
like she's like yeah you don't need to
punish yourself for that anymore no i'm
like
oh yeah
okay yeah
you did good job
it's really hard to like give yourself
praise i've never been a praise person
so it's hard to accept like compliments
especially from yourself because you're
like do you mean it
i remember my therapist and then a life
coach also
was like uh have you ever just told
yourself hey i really love you i was
like no yeah
they're like okay go to the mirror right
now and do it and i and looked at myself
i was like i look
yeah
you start crying like why is this so
hard they're like you've never done that
before i'm like no and like
it was crazy how i couldn't get the
words out yeah yeah it was hard for me
to accept love yeah growing up and in my
earlier relationships as a young adult
because i do believe we accept the kind
of love we think we deserve and if you
don't think you're worthy of having
someone to love every part of you even
the dark ugly bits then you'll have
someone who only recognizes those
that's so true you know yeah you attract
what you the type of you think you
deserve love internet mom yeah right
guys um from us your big sisters and
your internet that's our internet mom i
love you and you're valuable determined
to make
for you to make that tick tock because i
think it'll do great the two talk
account uh let yourself hug yourself
yeah
say that in the mirror say it in the
mirror or you can fall like a little
baby little baby [ __ ]
baby
baby you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] cry baby i
learned one thing that you can do every
night go to sleep pat yourself and be
like you did good today good job yeah
good job you did good today i love you
um but please follow jesley zama on all
of her socials we'll be linking it down
below yes thank you for being here today
thank you for having me you enhanced our
life i love you both and uh and let us
know in the comments if there's anything
that you've worked through that that has
helped you that has given you tools for
self-love i would love to know yeah
and give us a like thumbs up five stars
whatever it is i don't know but we love
you and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you